[Music]
the US women's ice hockey team provided
one of the most dramatic moments of the
Olympics so far a shootout win over
rival Canada gave the American women
their first gold medal since 1998 and
ended the Canadians 24 game Olympic
winning streak the 2018 Olympics were an
international affair for the Brant
family of Minnesota
Hannah Brant helped Team USA to the gold
medal while her adopted sister Marissa
who was born in South Korea represented
the unified Korean team Dana Jacobson
sat down with the sisters to discuss
their Olympic experiences yeah it was an
incredible feeling being able to be here
with my sister I'd kind of imagined what
it would be like coming into it but to
actually be able to live it out and do
it with her was one of the most
incredible feelings ever I didn't even
know what to expect going into the
Olympics and what it would be like but
know that it's almost over and sad but
we had so much fun together and with our
teams and yeah we I don't know couldn't
have asked for anything different
opening ceremony different teams but did
you get a chance to see each other at
least yes for a short time my team was
really late for some some reason there's
lots of traffic so got it right away and
then looked for the USA sine and found
her took a picture and then we said bye
yeah I was kind of sad because I was
like I'm not gonna see her like I was
kind of texting like you need to get
here now like and then I didn't hear
from her and all of a sudden we're about
to walk outside and I don't know where
she appeared and I was got a little
emotional just because I to actually see
her at the opening ceremonies and to
have that like dream come true for both
of us is pretty exciting Hannah
obviously for you this was the gold
medal that you all sought can you take
me into what it was like for you and for
your team your I mean you get to over
time you go to a shootout what was that
shootout like for you guys on the ice it
felt like we had a lot of confidence
going into overtime we were playing
while we'd come from behind and then for
it to go into a shootout we just kind of
really go up we got to do this now like
that cool that relaxed yeah I mean you
can't overthink it at that point it's
just a shootout we do those all the time
and obviously
I meant a little bit more but you have
to kind of stay calm cool and collected
I don't know if it's quite sunk in yet
but it's definitely a dream country for
all of us and it's just been fun to
experience that with my teammates can
you take us into that moment right that
second when you knew that the US had won
what was that like for the Brandt family
in the stands yeah we were all sitting
together and we were actually with some
of my teammates and I just remember she
made the save we all screamed and then
we ran down because we wanted to be like
we wanted to try and see you and be with
other parents but it was just excitement
pure excitement and joy and happiness
for her team and that they finally won
gold it was stressful to watch just
because you know yeah it was very back
and forth and like you said went into
overtime and then a shootout so I was on
the edge of my seat the entire time just
nervous for her and her team but they
won and it was complete just yeah so
happy and relieved that it was over and
she could celebrate and yeah very happy
and proud I know you guys spent about
what two years where you guys really
weren't in the same place as a family
not just you but with your parents one
of your sponsors helped bring you
together Intel how did they do that
Intel was awesome they came and shot
both of us in our respective training
locations for us to be able to kind of
share our story with our family and
friends that hadn't really seen a whole
lot of us even when you're not there I
know that I always have something to
play for and that's you guys it was
incredible the way they put that
together what do you think the impact
was on girls in America in Korea from
seeing you guys play hockey I've already
heard from so many people back home
people tweeting at us that we've
inspired many many people to start
playing hockey I think we've generated a
lot of new fans and I think for us to be
able to do that that's that's what we're
here to do we want to spread the game we
want to be role models for little girls
back home and I think that we were able
to do that right on Brant sisters sure
they sure did become role models well
and what a great experience for two
sisters I believe really
really